[Applause]
good evening for one day on from
confirmation of saints for his plans to
merge with Asda and serious questions
are being asked about the impact on
suppliers Saints preserve promote lunch
the deal is done it will cut the price
of everyday household items by 10% it
says the cost of this would be borne by
multinational suppliers who account for
85% of all goods sold by the two grocers
well is that true well I'm joined now by
Lord Haskins he's former chief executive
in northern foods which in his heyday
mates key Orbitz pea sausages and ready
meals for Marks and Spencer well good
evening to You Lord Haskins how would
you have reacted to a deal like this
when you were running northern foods I'd
have been a bit frightened because
obviously with the costs that they've
planning to take out somebody's got to
pay for those costs I'm sure they have
cost savings within the organisation
although they've said they don't plan to
mm these sorts tours but they've said
they're going to reduce their sales
prices on certain products by 10 percent
one of which would probably be milk and
I used to supply them as milk so that
would be trouble so how on earth can
supplies respond to this I mean
ultimately they're going to have to cut
costs themselves and potentially jobs
yeah I mean what will happen is there'll
be fewer but larger supplies is the
normal thing that happens here that some
of the bigger suppliers will get even
bigger because the volumes they'll be
given more volume and therefore be able
to compensate for the loss of margin but
that must mean that other suppliers
either bad ones or small ones will be
squeezed out well when we spoke to my
coop the Sainsbury's CEO on last night's
show he was stressing that most of their
that both companies supplies are big
multinationals the likes of Procter &
Gamble Unilever Kraft Heinz and so forth
do you think there's any way that they
can insulate smaller supplies from any
of this pain well in technology they can
they can buy locally from small local
suppliers they can certainly do that but
it's expensive and if the name of the
game this is entirely a defensive
a merger it isn't neither side are
paying cash to the other because they
don't want to put more money into the
supermarket business and they're all
about cost reduction so you you have to
be pretty firm and Steely minded when
you want to go and cut costs if you were
still an active participant in this
situation would you be urging the
competition and Markets Authority to be
blocking this deal I think it's
difficult under the present rules of
competition at the moment the remit is
to protect the interests of consumers
and it could well be a good deal for
consumers in that prices could drop
choices choice won't be very much
affected I think that the agreement for
computer games competition authorities
however should include the supply chain
to make sure that we're not going to
erode some very good companies as a
result of mass centralization of power
into fewer and fewer hands that has to
be wrong in the long term and I think
the worm is about to change
turn on that but not on this deal so do
you think this could actually drive
further consolidation among the supplies
themselves can you see them sort of
huddling together alongside each other
for warmth I'm sure that will happen I
mean just just as the retailers are
getting fewer in number then the
suppliers will with the exception
remember there are new types of outlets
for small suppliers local shops are
coming back a little bit into their own
local markets are coming back into the
little a little bit into their own and
they can hang on to this but for the
most part if I were in the business I'd
be making sure that my competitors in
the dairy industry they wanted to sit by
my business or I wanted to buy their
business but I'd be talking seriously to
them
very interesting that you say this is a
defensive move my coop was adamant
yesterday that he won't close any stores
as a result of this transaction but
surely the CMA are going to require
stall disposals and potentially in time
that could mean some stores do closed
well he may hope that the competition is
already does at the job forum
but they will want to he as what they
did with Safeway Morrison where they
were required to sell stores to
competitors in those days or plenty of
buyers for the story of course if the
market was growing if you put stores up
for sale at the moment there aren't
going to be very many people who want to
buy them one of the non-food retail
chains said to me the other day that
they were not going to take on any
leases for property in excess of ten
years and that tells me that they don't
have much confidence in the future
beyond the next ten years so who's going
to buy these stores well goodness I mean
you put works in this entire industry
all your working life can you think of
any other country in which the top two
grocery suppliers would have a combined
market share of getting on for 60% no I
don't think so there will be smaller
countries with that example I think I
think you'll find actually this in our
intestine deck Dunn's probably have got
something around that share of the
market but large countries like France
Germany the United States no they
wouldn't have the resource of shares
Walmart have a big big share in America
of course and of course the interesting
thing is Walmart's the biggest retailer
in the world is effectively getting out
of these markers by taking a minority
stake in this new company our Lord
Haskins we gotta leave it there great
pleasure talking to you thanks for
joining me